♪♪
-♪ Lil' T on the track, baby ♪
♪ Just got signed,
so we rich now, ha ♪
♪ Whole crew gon' eat ♪
♪ My girl Boo Boo,
my boy Mac with me ♪
♪ Yeah, we in the club,
actin' up like... ♪
♪ Came through the kitchen
on a Tuesday ♪
♪ Straight to the booth
for my crew ♪
♪ 'Bout to do things ♪
♪ Pop bottles,
new money...old ways ♪
♪ Penny for your thoughts, I got
a milly for the whole thing ♪
♪ Party's around me,
just drink and don't speak ♪
♪ Shrimp tower, what's that,
we don't eat ♪
♪ Give 'em tips
with change we don't need ♪
♪ Don't worry 'bout a thing
'cause it's all on me ♪
♪ Lil' T winnin',
now it's all on me ♪
♪ Get what you want ♪
-♪ It's all on me ♪
-♪ Wear shades 'cause my shine
is all you'll see ♪
♪ Black card to black card,
it's all on me ♪
♪ Run the check up
'cause it's all on me ♪
♪ What's that? ♪
♪ 'Cause it's all on me ♪
-The check, sir.
-♪ 'Cause it's all on me ♪
Oh, cool.
♪ 'Cause it's all on -- ♪
[ Gasps ] Oh, my God!
[ High-pitched whining ]
[ Heart beat thumping ]
-[Muffled] Baby?
Baby, what's wrong?
-Uh, hm? Oh, nothin', Boo.
Heh. Don't worry 'bout it.
♪ Hey, Mac, hm, tell 'em
how you livin', bruh ♪
-♪ T give me that dough ♪
♪ And I'm wylin' ♪
-♪ No doubt ♪
♪ Got the whole crew
drippin' in diamonds ♪
♪ Diamonds on my chain ♪
♪ Ten diamond rangs ♪
-Ten?
-♪ Diamonds on my grill ♪
-Okay.
-♪ Diamonds for my girl,
Benz for my girl ♪
-♪ House for my girl ♪
-Hey, Mac
-♪ Benz for my house ♪
-No.
-♪ House for my Benz ♪
-What?
♪ Benz for my moms,
Benz for my kids ♪
-They babies!
-♪ 'Cause it's all on him ♪
♪ Run the check up ♪
-♪ 'Cause it's all on me ♪
♪ Some's on me,
'cause it's all on me ♪
♪ Or us, though,
Who ordered this shrimp?
♪ 'Cause it's all on me ♪
♪ Nobody eatin' it ♪
That ain't good.
♪ 'Cause it's all on me ♪
-♪ You can tell by the way
he throw it all around ♪
♪ He got money in the bank ♪
-♪ It's all on T ♪
-♪ Okay, Lil' T,
you up in the big leagues ♪
♪ See you spendin' big G's
like your boy Freddie G ♪
♪ Young'uns making money
is something I like to see ♪
♪ Send him one big bottle
of Ace, it's on me ♪
-♪ Damn, Freddie Gibbs,
you doin' it like that ♪
-♪ You know the club code,
gotta send something back ♪
-♪ I already know,
yo, send something dope ♪
♪ Enjoy, Freddie Gibbs ♪
-♪ What's this? Diet Coke ♪
The [bleep]
Boy, I should whup your ass
for bringing this [bleep]
damn Coke over here, boy.
♪ Old dude's just being cheap ♪
♪ Shots for everybody,
and they all on T ♪
♪ Run the check up
'cause it's all on T ♪
♪ He got it ♪
-No, it's not.
-♪ Yeah, it's all on T ♪
-♪ Ha, Freddie Gibbs
doesn't represent me, though ♪
-♪ Now, hold up, baby,
let me get 'em ♪
♪ Cristal poppin'
in the V.I.P. ♪
♪ I got my own money,
but he spendin' on me ♪
♪ Get ten more bottles ♪
-♪ Let's start with one ♪
-♪ Five Dom Perignons ♪
-♪ Let's start with none ♪
-♪ And all you hos in the club,
look but don't touch ♪
♪ Gotta go through me first,
now eat your box lunch ♪
♪ Throw that money up ♪
♪ Whole spot goin' crazy ♪
-Word.
-♪ 'Cause I'm havin'
Lil' T's baby ♪
-You're pregnant?!
-♪ It's all on T ♪
-That's why
you're not drinkin'?!
-♪ It's all on T ♪
-I thought there was,
like, a holy reason.
I'm so stressed.
-♪ It's all on T ♪
-I'm not financially prepared
to be a father.
-Hey, let's close
this out right, T.
♪♪
-♪ Everybody,
put your hands in the sky ♪
♪ Now drop 'em
low to the floor ♪
♪ Now pull your credit card
out your pocket ♪
♪ And pass it to me, bro ♪
♪ Oh, who got a Venmo? ♪
♪ Send me a Venmo,
who got a Venmo? ♪
♪ I need like ten mo' ♪
♪ Ow, ow, bah, ow, ow ♪
♪ 'Cause it's all on me ♪
Hey, can you go ahead
and split these up evenly
between all these?
Thank you very much.
It's very important.
♪ 'Cause it's all on me ♪